[Aplausos]
[Música]
no necesita ser presentada es la empresa
más grande más admirada y más exitosa de
todo el mundo
cada minuto factura más de 400 mil
dólares y su facturación anual supera
los 215 mil millones de dólares
nunca en la historia una empresa había
sido tan admirada había crecido tanto o
había ganado todo este dinero sus
números son sencillamente colosales su
inversión en i + d es tan grande como la
de toda españa' y el dinero que gana
cada año supera a lo que ganan países
como emiratos kuwait o canadá con la
venta de petróleo impresionante
si quieres comprarla prepara la cartera
para hacer té con ella vas a tener que
poner sobre la mesa más de 750 mil
millones de dólares tal cual es tan
grande que prácticamente ningún gobierno
del mundo podría comprarla
hablamos como no de apple
[Música]
pero como se dice aquí en visual
político esperad un momento porque en
este vídeo no vamos a hablar de jobs ni
del iphone 8 ni de ningún tipo de ipad
en este vídeo vamos a echar un vistazo a
la dimensión a la influencia ya la
estrategia y también a los problemas de
apple en su conjunto
muñoz
ipad
[Música]
la década inolvidable del iphone hace 10
años el 29 de junio del 2007 apple lanzó
al mercado el iphone es justo que nos
paremos un momento aquí porque amigos el
iphone ha sido uno de los productos con
más éxito de la historia
en apenas 10 años se han vendido cerca
de 1300 millones de iphones y apple ha
facturado con ello ojo al dato más de
800 mil millones de dólares
hablamos por tanto de uno de los más
grandes negocios de la historia de la
humanidad
pero no penséis que su influencia se
limita a ello para nada el iphone- ha
tenido un impacto descomunal en todas
nuestras vidas y también en muchos
sectores de la economía
fijaos el legendario steve jobs dijo del
iphone que era algo así como unos tres
productos en uno solo y la verdad se
equivocó por completo el iphone y los
teléfonos inteligentes se han tragado a
montones de productos e industrias como
las de los reproductores de mp3 las
cámaras de fotos las de vídeo los gps
los relojes y así un largo etcétera
si podemos decir que el iphone ha sido
la peor pesadilla para muchas industrias
fijaos en estos datos porque reflejan
muy bien lo rápido que cambian las cosas
desde que apple lanzó el iphone la venta
de cámaras digitales ha caído casi un 70
por ciento la de mp3 un 87 por ciento la
de gps sistemas de navegación un 80 por
ciento y la de cámaras de vídeos un
terrorífico 93 por ciento
vamos que aquí el concepto de
destrucción creativa se aprecia en toda
su dimensión eso sí al tiempo que todas
esas industrias se han venido abajo
otras han surgido con fuerza hablamos
claramente de los desarrolladores de
aplicaciones y también de nuevos modelos
de negocio como uber spotify igual a
popa sin el iphone los creadores de
software serían mucho más pobres las
aplicaciones que desarrollan para estos
teléfonos les generan más de 20 mil
millones de dólares cada año pero hasta
aquí todos conocéis perfectamente al
iphone los smartphones y todo lo que han
supuesto de hecho una de cada dos
personas que estén viendo este vídeo lo
estáis haciendo desde un
inteligente así que vayamos a la primera
pregunta clave que le ha supuesto
realmente apple toda este impresionante
década de éxitos
[Música]
y una máquina de hacer dinero
mira amigos cada vez que apple presenta
resultados hay un momento un instante en
el que tienen la sensación de que el
mundo se ha parado y de repente boom
explosión de reacciones y titulares de
todos los tipos y colores que si el
resultado es histórico que si el
crecimiento no es el esperado pero por
encima de todo si tomamos perspectiva no
podemos olvidar que apple es el mayor
negocio la mayor máquina de hacer dinero
de toda la historia empresarial como os
dije en el vídeo que hice sobre amazon
como no aquí en visual polític por
cierto os dejo el enlace en la
descripción y también al final de este
vídeo para saber si una empresa gana o
no dinero dinero de verdad contante y
sonante a mí me gusta fijarme en el
dinero que realmente entra y sale de la
empresa pues bien sabéis que el caso de
apple sencillamente no tiene precedentes
tan solo en los últimos cinco años la
empresa ha generado después incluso de
descontar el dinero que ha dedicado a
inversión hay más de o a comprar
empresas la sorprendente cantidad de 250
mil 979 millones de dólares
es decir como os comentaba antes muchas
petromonarquías del golfo pérsico no
dudarían ni un segundo en cambiar el
negocio del petróleo por uno como el de
apple pensad que solo esta compañía es
capaz de ganar más dinero que kuwait
qatar o emiratos con todo el petróleo y
el gas natural es de sobresaliente y
sorprendentemente apple no ha
despilfarrado todo ese dinero comprando
a diestro y siniestro empresas a precio
de oro algo muy común en los mercados
financieros para nada apple compra una
empresa cada tres o cuatro semanas pero
a diferencia de lo que suele ser
habitual elige muy bien sus objetivos
compras sobre todo estar a apps con
nuevas apuestas tecnológicas pero claro
puede que os estoy preguntando qué hace
apple con todo este dinero pues
básicamente ahorrar y premiar a sus
accionistas
apple tiene sus cuentas bancarias más de
250 mil millones de dólares la mayor
cantidad de efectivo acumulada nunca por
una empresa que cotiza en bolsa y por
otro lado en los últimos cinco años la
empresa se ha gastado la friolera de 180
mil millones de dólares en premiar a sus
accionistas
sé que es fácil perderse con estas
cifras tan grandes así que para que os
hagáis una idea os diré que tan solo con
el dinero que tiene ahorrado apple
podría pagar íntegramente todo el
presupuesto de la nasa en la próxima
década o en otras palabras si se lo
propusiese apple podría llegar antes a
marte que el mismísimo gobierno de los
eeuu no está mal para una sola empresa
verdad
[Música]
ahora ya podéis entender por qué apple
tiene una valoración tan alta en el
mercado y por qué hasta el mismísimo
warren buffett el inversor más
legendario de todos los tiempos ha
decidido apostar por esta empresa
[Música]
el nuevo emblema de eeuu un tiempo en el
que los coches de la general motors las
películas del oeste los bancos de wall
street o las hamburguesas de mcdonald's
fueron los emblemas de eeuu la muestra
su prosperidad y su poder económico
hoy ese puesto le corresponde claramente
a apple ojo sí que algunos estaré
diciendo pero si casi todos sus
productos se ensamblan en china es
verdad pero su tecnología es pura
norteamericana algo que por cierto se
encargan de recordar en todos sus
productos y esto tiene un efecto claro
en la economía
se calcula que apple ha creado directa o
indirectamente 2 millones de empleos en
eeuu trabaja además con cientos de
proveedores en el país y ha impulsado el
surgimiento de nuevas actividades
empresariales que han puesto a eeuu a la
cabeza- tecnológica del mundo
el mejor ejemplo de todo esto es el peso
que apple ha logrado en la mismísima
china la gran potencia adversaria de
eeuu solo en este país
appel facturó en el último ejercicio más
de 48.000 millones de dólares una cifra
mayor que todos los ingresos de cocacola
en todo el mundo claro que no todos de
color de rosas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
las sombras en el universo apple
precisamente algunos de los grandes
quebraderos de cabeza para los
ejecutivos de apple proceden del lejano
oriente especialmente de china y la
india en china a pesar de las cifras en
bruto lleva más de cinco trimestres
consecutivos viendo caer sus resultados
entre otras cosas porque apple parece
estar enfrentada con tensión la empresa
propietaria de widget la aplicación
china por excelencia que lo hace casi
todo y que puede estar preparando su
propio smartphones el caso es que a
pesar de los esfuerzos que están
haciendo en apple les está costando
encajar en el mercado chino y eso desde
luego es un problema
por ejemplo la retención de apel entre
los usuarios de iphones supera el 80% en
eeuu o reino unido mientras que en china
es sólo del 50% por su parte en la india
que se espera que sea el mercado que
registre mayor crecimiento en los
próximos años la presencia de apple es
como decir lo marginal apenas tiene el
3% de cuota de mercado
aquí la compañía está intentándolo todo
pero de momento las cosas no marchan del
todo bien y luego amigos está la
dependencia del iphone y las fuertes
expectativas que siempre genera apple
hoy por hoy el teléfono supone casi el
70% de todos los ingresos de la compañía
y hay quien se pregunta es qué acaso
apple ya no sabe innovar pero para ser
justos todos estos son problemas
inevitables en un mercado competitivo y
desde luego la posición competitiva de
apple hoy por hoy sigue siendo excelente
tal vez lo que pasa es que esta compañía
ha situado muy arriba el punto de
exigencia y nos ha malacostumbrado el
iphone 7 lleva a pela
mestre de mayores ventas de su historia
y además no podemos olvidar que para una
empresa tan grande quiere decir ya no es
algo tan sencillo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y qué pasa con el futuro
si algo ha demostrado apple hasta ahora
es que es una empresa que sabe hacer las
cosas bien probablemente ninguna empresa
está enseguida de cerca y tan
continuamente evaluada como lo es apple
por las decenas de miles de seguidores
incondicionales que se ha granjeado con
el paso del tiempo bueno pues a pesar de
ello la sensación es que mejor o peor la
empresa siempre cumple el caso es que
frente a lo que pueda parecer todo
apunta a que apple tiene una estrategia
marcada que sigue contra viento y marea
la idea de apple para los próximos
tiempos es seguir mejorando el iphone
sin grandes disrupciones por ejemplo
incorporando la realidad aumentada o la
inteligencia artificial de siri la idea
es convertirlo en un gran cerebro para
un ecosistema de gran valor un
ecosistema amigos que comienza con los
propios servicios vinculados a sus
productos entre ellos están apple music
icloud la appstore o apple page esta
última por cierto una de las grandes
promesas de la compañía según muchos
analistas apple sueña con convertirse en
todo un intermediario financiero y que
apple pay venga a ser algo así como una
nueva visa quién sabe
y ojo porque esta división de servicios
es ya la segunda de apel y la que más
crece cada año genera más de 25 mil
millones de dólares
[Música]
luego está la expansión de los
complementos que dependen del propio
terminal como el apple watch o los
airport y aquí las cosas a decir verdad
tampoco le están yendo mal a la compañía
apple se ha convertido ya en la mayor
compañía de oro bolsa de dispositivos
corporales del mundo
en esta línea muchos expertos dan por
hecho el próximo lanzamiento de gafas
inteligentes y nuevos sensores por
ejemplo para la ropa y los accesorios
domésticos
y como tercer pilar está lograr que sus
productos se integren en las cadenas de
valor industrial y profesional por
ejemplo en hospitales despachos de
ingeniería o fábricas es decir
complementar su línea de consumo con
unos bienes de capital hay que decir que
de esto se viene hablando hace tiempo
pero los resultados hasta ahora han sido
un tanto decepcionantes
también está no podría faltar claro lo
que podemos calificar como la búsqueda
de la innovación disruptiva de vez en
cuando viene un producto revolucionario
que lo cambia todo así es apple tiene ya
una división trabajando en el futuro
posterior al iphone entre sus trabajos
está el llamado proyecto titán para
desarrollar aparentemente una plataforma
de transporte autónomo veremos de
momento en la compañía de la manzana
parece haber muchos proyectos la empresa
ha contratado a muchos diseñadores y
profesionales de diferentes sectores y
sus ambiciones son grandes pero hasta
ahora la dependencia del iphone es total
amigos sólo el tiempo podrá confirmar si
apple consigue no mantenerse en primera
posición de momento todo lo conseguido
es impresionante y además cultura
recursos y experiencia le sobran a esta
empresa turno para ti eres más de
android o de ellos déjanos tu respuesta
en los comentarios y también en esta
encuesta si te ha gustado el vídeo no te
olvides de en darle a like y suscribirte
al canal por cierto si quieres saber más
sobre amazon échale un vistazo a este
vídeo
un saludo y hasta la próxima
ipad
es winter in band